chief Washington correspondent major
Garrett is here with CBS News special
correspondent Alex Wagner who's also
co-host of the circus on Showtime a
division of Viacom CBS good morning
tomorrow morning time I know at least
you were at that rally as well thousands
of others here's a problem for president
Trump those are the diehards he walked
and talked to those voters many of them
are out in 2016 but he's got to expand
the electorate in 2020 to win again so
he lost here by about 2,800 votes and
made a reckless charge last night that
there was some vote fraud there New
Hampshire has thoroughly investigated
that up one side down the other a
completely false allegation laying it
out there as part of this trumpian idea
that it was a close loss but somebody
did something wrong to me completely
factually incorrect
and yet the president keeps going back
to that here insulting essentially the
whole entire New Hampshire electoral
process and the investigations and
allegations of voter fraud does that
suggest this state is to him winning in
2020 it sticks in his craw he lost
narrowly he wants to win again but look
at 2018 Democrats gained across the
state County local state and federal
offices so there's a lot of enthusiasm
here the president trying to counter
program his way around that if you can
Alex you've had an opportunity to look
up close and some of that enthusiasm as
you crisscross the state with Democrats
looking to replace President Trump
Sanders and Budaj leading in the polls
who has got the edge for the last couple
days Pete Budaj edge in his campaign has
been sort of going toe to toe with Amy
Klobuchar are talking about crowd sighs
I have 1,800 you have 1,100 last night
Bernie Sanders held a rally in Durham
New Hampshire and there were 7,500
people in the audience Tony it is you
care there was live music there was live
music but I spent a lot of time on that
line talking to the people who are going
in there and they were interested in
Bernie Sanders it was not about the
strokes it was not about AOC it was
about Bernie Sanders and it is an
indicator of the depth of the support he
has and the emotional there is an
emotional core to to the Sanders
supporters that does not exist anywhere
else in this Democratic New Hampshire
has a reputation for leveling
frontrunners but also potentially
elevating underdogs and I want to get a
question about Amy Klobuchar because she
seems to be rising in the polls she
doesn't listen I think Joe Biden's
decline is also related to Amy Klobuchar
as a cent but I spent
with amy klobuchar she works harder than
almost anybody in this race which is
saying a lot because everybody's working
really hard
a lot of her campaign is propelled by
the candidates own momentum and her
ability to just press the flesh and
connect with voters on a really intimate
level and had two great nights here
Friday night at the debate Saturday
night at the big dinner that they had at
the main arena where Trump was last
night there's a slingshot effect that
sometimes happens in New Hampshire
someone has a really great bit of
momentum that's surprising and boom they
run to the top or get near the top I
think she's in a strong position to
finish third and if it's a close close
third like right behind Bernie and Pete
that will be a big news story and it
will be a deep disappointment to
Elizabeth Warren who spent months and
months and months organizing here it
could fastidiously and that organization
may not be enough - that is a huge
jewelry line the loser of this is a big
storyline thank you both very much and
that is indeed a very big storyline
because as we send it back to you guys
in New York it's important to remember
that no major party nominee has ever
gone on out of New Hampshire without
finishing in the top two so people in
three and four
their campaigns historically speaking
may be over no we're looking for that
slingshot effect thanks Tony